for happy wheels yes
no victory sound 95% impossible I
appreciate when they have realistic odds
what the hell is what is it what is that
oh this is the most horrifying thing
I've seen all of happy wheels down down
the world flip yeah oh babe flip no flip
I am and you missed me Boosh
rainbow poon run take it again I'm
cutting around the corner my ass
fighting me why I don't care about you
kid it's in my ass
only pros to as you all know I am a
proponent haha didn't get me to proud
you just took the kid ha ha ha I go
above you I got above you YouTube or
Facebook I don't imagine someone
completely different
I don't turn back Kurds logs on a pogo
level kinda you so much
are you crow I am a pro hello everybody
welcome to you are you a pro today we'll
find a laugh [ __ ] off
generic RC Jeff fallen you worse I'm far
too Pro to be beaten by the likes of
that
so I don't I don't even I don't even
need my bike I am - damn bro shall be
written by the likes of you
hahaha
oh yeah I'm rigidly stuck to my bike I
can't maneuver ah just die old man you
better wait a minute this is not right
hey God there we go die you bastard you
old bastard
hello ladies ha ha oh I'm just too
strong for you a little Elvin kid I've
heard that you're a douche
come here thank you or now in my cone
you're not my father
whoa wait a minute huh there always is
this question if you met your clone
would you okay
I just sat I couldn't pick Santa for
this one saying us better at pogoing the
new happy sword throw happy fun times
hello family how are you doing today
will endure dudes little kitty or jump
into my arms little Billy
jump into my arms I'm intentionally miss
you too good all right Kyle a warm toast
or a little bit of glass fun so bastard
[Music]
father all throw to all three of you
what's with a little kid ha Bisky three
balls
ah three balls obviously burden - okay
no death no death I say not to death
hey brewski balls ha ha ha ha yes yes -
help
No
this one's a good one
hi Persky uh plus help yay thank you
hahaha no more death for me I what oh no
no no now get better boss it's my last
shot
give it give it to me give it to me okay
wait a minute cuz that's what doesn't
even make any sense at all ah 99 when I
first sent impossible whoopsies
ah ha ha did not hurt me I'm invincible
invincible aha my legs but I am still
alive what's this proneness ha what's
this ha oh let backward the roll ha ha
ha
backwards super somersault my legs were
just holding me back you will see that
victory will be mine wills girl I can do
super tricks now you just wish you were
cool like me where's my car hell no this
is almost better method of propulsion
vision yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
try this again I said all right let's
try this again
[Music]
sore throat wow that is a lot of sward
throwing hahaha oh you almost got me
there buddy flash right up your nards
hurts go ski don't say these epic moves
I am dueling
oh no don't kill me on did not kill me
that - no don't kill me
I can't even kill myself I'm so good I'm
so hurrah
Oh swore throw duel well oh you are not
the real Santa Claus ah ah you come back
for another bath whooping you can't
please enlighten me I am too much of a
professional voice our only new are
young kids they don't know what's best
oh is that our best you can't believe me
no all right let's give this another try
said I think you're good to mama
I'd say you're better than me
ha ho ho ho Sanna never dies there must
always be our fan call sonic zone why
would the pogo guy be in a sonic zone
right don't loose ball go down there cut
I know you can fit in there good good
keep going
the warmer Jeff you're good you're good
you're good you're good you're good
neighbor son my son wait hang on I gotta
think about this a little bit you know
right okay good now I tried my best
come on son goodbye forever alright I'll
really save you this time is it working
[Music]
I'm good
cool sward throw Garner's Lucy haha you
were holding on for dear life and then I
destroyed you I got hey baby baby baby
girl bye buddy
[Music]
epic best rope swing huh hey wait no
it's right I said it
Oh ball throw and surprise I hope it's a
good one
so I minded like the last ones that I do
what the hell what is that
Oh Wyatt Raskin Depok baltra haskers oh
ha ha ha Warren I'm in a desert dune
buggy of sorts ha backflip oh [ __ ] slam
dunk
oopsies base alright guys were on
another ball go jump to sweetings words
per usual
no no we've got how does it help Sara
low Castlevania Symphony of the Night
with one no her man because this makes
sense
shut up zombies oh my god Wow and bran
world
what are these portal creatures oh my
god what the who are they stop throwing
things at me you jerk huh suck it oh
[ __ ]
stop throwing things at me I that
doesn't seem like it should hurt me that
badly it was just a small thingy
Oh epic block epic block epic mock epic
nah ow ow ow hey I'm trying to get I'm
crunch over now ah ah kill your freakin
boss I will kill my boss kill my boss
wait
[Music]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]